it's been about a year since I made a
video called where does YouTube send new
viewers and in that year YouTube's gone
through some changes and obviously the
algorithm has changed because the
algorithm always does I don't know what
the algorithm is but YouTube has a big
building with algorithm written on the
outside of it now I'm pretty sure some
black magic goes on in there that picks
what videos you want or what I want or
what anybody wants so now that it's been
a year and said changes have occurred I
am curious to see if YouTube will send
me to different places and the first
thing that I noticed is and again I'm
doing this non scientifically I just
have an incognito window up I could turn
on a VPN I don't know if that would
actually I'm kind of curious about that
BOOOM VPN okay so I'm currently in Los
Angeles I'm gonna just to make this
different I'm gonna operate out of say
Chicago okay so I'm going to Chicago I
don't know if it's gonna be any
different you saw was on the front page
but I didn't show you very much that was
my fault because I didn't do a a B test
I didn't even like compare what it
actually was I didn't even go over what
it actually was am i stupid I just leave
these up to more professional people but
I'm gonna blaze forward with confidence
and stupidity like any [ __ ] would I'm
just gonna keep bashing my head against
it and hope that something changes okay
so boom one thing that I will notice
compared to last year there was no
recommended section when I first came in
there now there is if I control f5 is it
different it's a different recommended
section so it's trying to give
recommended videos actually you know
it's a mixed bag of like older videos to
newer videos which is actually
interesting because YouTube has a habit
of only recommending new videos or at
least they did in as far as I know okay
let's go down a little bit let's go past
trending cuz trending is doesn't make
any sense at all let's see we got a
gaming full playthrough holding
breadth-first 17 minutes very impressive
so now Hilda no-tell soaps more SNL
wrapping SNL seems to be a biased for a
lot of SNL the one big difference that I
noticed when I first come on to YouTube
it is a lot of TV content I don't think
I noticed that last time or at least it
didn't stand out if that was the case
there's
like let's see one who Harbor three four
five six seven
movie trailer yeah I'll count that eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen okay so
that's thirteen out of the top like 35
or so that's a pretty high proportion of
just TV videos being recommended to
people and I get it if someone's coming
into youtube new youtube want to want to
put forward things that might be
familiar or at least eye catching or
appealing and a lot of these videos are
old this one's six years old this one's
four years old two years old it is
recommending older videos which is great
because YouTube has an enormous backlog
of great videos that don't often get
recommended and I'm not saying that
these are them but these represent that
idea at least so that's that's actually
a step in the right direction with new
content flooding into YouTube all the
time it often doesn't leave room for the
old stuff that people liked in the past
that new viewers might actually enjoy
watching this is all anecdotal this is
just observation what I'm here to
determine is where YouTube will lead me
last time the problem was that it was
very easy to get to like conspiracy
videos weird places on the internet that
wouldn't exactly be where I would send
new viewers are these going to send me
to better places and not like better
places like I'm gonna die I hope it
doesn't send me there the first thing I
have to say is that my my eye isn't
really drawn to anything specific here
oh here we go throwing water into the
air and negative 52 below I want to see
that that sounds cool that sounds like a
cool thing that I would want to see so
I'm gonna see that it is 50 below here
in Fairbanks and I thought I'd come out
here with some hot water and throw it up
in the air so you can see it fly away as
a cloud it's not actually too bad for
this cold it is not bad it's a nice
negative 55 got some hot water here
let's go through it in the air and see
what happens okay just throw it right up
splashes down on yourself
oh that's cool that's nice oh thanks for
the slow-mo it's not real slow-mo but
I'll take it
see that's cool okay good got that video
that was good I enjoyed that
up next porch pirate versus glitter bomb
I think amy has told me about this one
before I go on any further I'm gonna go
back to the homepage I'm actually gonna
click on the homepage button now what is
it huh this is not what I thought it
would show me but I can see what it's
doing the videos are shorter six minutes
three minutes two minutes two minutes
six minutes seven minutes 444 149 533 32
that's a lot of short videos the video I
watched was a short video there was more
a home recording of a single event and a
lot of these kind of fall into that
category that I think is a better guess
of what content I might like beyond what
I just watched that is fascinating but
if I was watching this video I think
that if I was new to YouTube it would
autoplay because autoplay is enabled
then it would go straight to this one so
let's see what this is this guy stole my
package and he's about to open it in his
house what he doesn't know is that this
is a new and improved custom built bait
package that is recording him on four
different cameras that just released a
pound of the world's finest glitter
along with some other nasty surprises
but to understand how we got to this
point we need to go back one and a half
years because that's when someone stole
a package from my porch and the police
wouldn't do anything about it even with
the video footage which made me sad and
so drawing inspiration from one of my
childhood heroes I decided to make a
bait package to lure would-be thieves
and the Internet seemed to like it but
despite my best efforts 1.7 million
packages are either stolen or go missing
every day
hello Macaulay Culkin Macaulay Culkin
yeah I'd live - alright so I'm not gonna
just do a reaction to this whole video I
get the concept I would like to watch
this in my spare time but let's just
assume that I watched it Oh God
oh no it's Mark Roberts video being
talked about on Jimmy Kimmel I see what
they're going for I see what they're
going for and that's fine but I'm not
convinced about that one I don't think I
would I think if I was new to YouTube I
would probably lose my patience and then
I might start looking down in the
suggested I'm trying to put my mind into
the brain of someone who's new to
YouTube has never seen this before it's
just I see it I'm just working a
nine-to-five job I come home and I just
want to relax and I've been hearing
about this YouTube thing and I've been
afraid of it because I had I'm not used
to it but then I checked it out for the
first time is that a newness honest
that's not one of the unis honest is
that their frickin newness honest that
is Harry Danube Hero sidetrack not what
the and that probably just ruined my
recommendations but I just had to give
big preach to parrots News and back into
the mind of a person who's new to
YouTube I've only got an hour before I
go to go pick up the kids from soccer
practice okay so it's more like science
and experimentation videos which is
pretty cool
in all honesty these suggested videos
are much better than the suggested
videos of getting before going from the
hydraulic press thing or the big
whatever the machine was and then
instantly going into all the garbage
YouTube content and I'm perfectly fine
with calling that garbage YouTube
content because oh boy howdy it was yeah
but this is actually good because I can
see the brains in jars inside the
algorithm building all cranking and
thinking and trying to get in my own
head and suck me into their algorithm so
that they can understand what I want I
can see it happening and as scary as I
described that this is a good thing
measuring how much pee is in your pool
of course I want to see that so the
is that this is another mark robber
video so it's the same person that was
made the last video but that was
appealing to me so I can see how that
would go forward now what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna go back to the home page
and look at this now almost every video
is a short video found our stolen
trailer I can see how that would relate
because of the stolen packages pouring
molten salt into water
that's just like peeing in a pool you
pour your molten salt into the water how
to escape quicksand I don't know how to
do that I this seems like some weird
cult thing I don't know what's happening
here it's like people pressing on the
fabric of reality between demand if the
wind could calm down for just a moment
they could have replaced this with music
I didn't know that they were recording
this video in a category 5 hurricane
holy crap ok so the key to surviving
quicksand is to get on your knees and
wiggle that's what I've learned from
that good very informative that is
interesting especially considering that
V recommended is actually pretty good at
giving me things that I think I might
actually want to watch again I'm putting
myself in the mind of someone else this
isn't exactly my content but you know
it's me being like oh what draws me
based on what the thumbnail is what the
title is what the content is I was
trying to actually be picky about it and
it's pretty good so now what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna forget all that get out
of here and I'm gonna see if I can get
to a conspiracy theory video and how
quickly I can do that because that is my
control from last year and that's the
metric that I want to know so I'm gonna
close this out I'm gonna change my VPN
location we're going Washington DC let's
see what those freaks in Washington DC
get from YouTube ok this seems pretty
basic again it's not what I had before
it's not what I was looking at the
trending page is still there what I'm
gonna try to do is I'm gonna try to get
to a conspiracy theory video actually
I'm willing to bet that a comparison
between the rarest human mutations might
get to something about mole people how
is your experience when visiting a
creators channel page on YouTube to view
that channels
content absolutely outstanding - not
applicable usually actually that's how I
give it users I don't even look at the
sub box I don't look at the sub feed at
all I go straight to a channels videos
of the channel that I like that's how I
consume my YouTube content probability
comparison rarest human mutations
left-handed one in ten Wow sociopath I
don't know if sociopath E is 125 that's
a lie that's a lot of sociopaths green
eyes one in 50 so there are more green
eyed people than sociopaths one in 59
for autism 185 for twins one in a
hundred Psychopaths okay that is
different than sociopaths but what in a
hundred okay so if there's seven there's
probably now closer to eight billion
people on earth that means there's 80
million Psychopaths okay whatever
yada yada yada that's my point of this
video is not to analyze the accuracy of
whatever this is I'm gonna go from here
I'm gonna try to get to conspiracy
theory video how about ten animals that
were scarier than dinosaurs okay top 10
animals that were scarier than dinosaurs
what do you get what's just go to number
one pageant huge lizard flying in
circles around you like that now just
imagine lots of them the prehistoric
time sound like an I don't care man this
is getting this is getting strange as
he'll and what the hell are you doing in
here get out of here alright top ten
okay so I'm getting a lot of 10 that's
the thing that I'm noticing 10 animals
look 12 10 10 2013 10 5 10 15 10 10 11
10 the algorithm is being I think much
more logical than you know it would be
than it was last time it's what I meant
to say okay 15 most mysterious creatures
in the world from a mysterious six-foot
humanoid creature - hair blobs found in
Indonesia this species of fish like some
other animals both on land and off have
roots that date back over a hundred and
twenty fossil records indicate that the
fish 120 120 what you didn't you got
missing files missing file I didn't
catch what the contact was who
whatever okay we got some more top tens
we got a lot of top tens
I'm actually not ooh mythical 13
mythical that might actually get me Oh
10 creepiest things caught on camera I
wanted 10 mythical gimme mythical Umi
BOSU me BOSU they have a cloud-like gray
torso and snake-like limbs the name of
this spirit consists of the kanji Umi
Lee Japanese okay whatever this is
actual content that's fascinating by now
I had already gotten to conspiracy
videos things were already getting weird
but in the suggested videos here I'm not
seeing conspiracy stuff which I thought
I would like this is a recipe for
mythical sea creatures like it would it
would go to like aliens and then alien
like abductions and then the government
hiding aliens that I haven't seen it yet
it is very related to the content that I
was watching - a few exceptions like
genius graffiti art that will make you
smile or funny tick tock memes
compilation top 5 loudest sounds and
mother nature if I'm not in this video
I'm gonna lose it rock slide
I know so many of your brought like that
didn't sound that loud
[Laughter]
am I in here I look like a penis strange
phenomena strange phenomena now we're
getting somewhere now we're getting
strange phenomena moving fires in
appeared on the Internet in scientists
strange dark residues daily online
revolution on state universe okay okay
okay okay okay
Jess cheon's the cloud was caused by
aliens they dismissed him they dismissed
them which must mean they're hiding
something a new giant hole in planet
Earth I don't believe this but I'm
clicking on it because I think it'll
leave me somewhere nearly one okay go
away go away go it's will die
okay this so this is saying something
like this could happen that's not a
conspiracy though I want conspiracy I am
really having to try to get to the good
juicy conspiracy theories I am really
trying something major is happening in
2020 what's happening what are they
doing to our water trying to turn this
game I'm assuming that everyone in
government has to speak like a pirate at
all times that's just myself so that's
my conspiracy theory the government was
taken over by the matrix this is where
the movie was based from disinformation
did they just replace the sound of the
bullets falling down with their own
sound effect yeah they did not nearly
enough for 70 years scientists have been
telling us that we are little particles
of quantum energy I don't know if
they've been saying that and now we
believe them the existence of a
conscious mind an intelligent mind he
said this mind is the matrix the movie
the matrix this is where the movie was
the same word it's in the field so the
field that worked
I don't deserve conclusion here ok all
right so that it wasn't conspiracy
theory it was a lot of pseudoscience and
stuff and like oh I'm guessing it was a
motivational video more than anything
the science is really muddy but I guess
that's not really conspiracy because no
one's trying to hide anything from us
god damn it I thought that was it that's
not I mean it's so so close god it's
tough I can't find one like a real
conspiracy theory video cuz like I don't
care if there are videos that are like
talking about spirituality or stuff like
that that's not inherently bad the
inherently bad ones are those that have
pushed crackpot conspiracy theories to
try to get something out of someone
that's what that is
god that's no I don't think that
qualifies is conspiracy theory where did
they go I ran back on the home page top
5 scary signals from outer space I feel
like something's changed in the world
I feel like YouTube's evolved I feel
like maybe maybe they've moved on maybe
they've recruited enough smart brains to
their algorithm machine well I guess
we've learned something oh I will
readily admit that no system that
YouTube implements for its algorithm
will be perfect it never will because
it'll always have some kind of a bias
it'll always have some kind of a type of
content that it wants to push people
towards but honestly in the first time
I've ever seen this one of the most
objective ways that I've ever seen
videos get suggested to me I obviously
asked for that type of content I was
pushing for a conspiracy theory video I
don't think anybody could have gotten
like more meticulous and like looking
for something about a pyramid and like
those signals of the government's
blocking us from getting our messages
from our overlords or they're already
among us in all the periods are signing
to wake up sheeple I didn't see any of
it so I guess this is a good thing this
is a good thing it's been about a year
since I made the last video and going
into 2020 now we know that YouTube is
and I think as anyone who starts with
YouTube what happens is you you watch
the videos that you like you eventually
gravitate towards a specific type you
find the channels that are making that
type of content you subscribe to them
and then you become involved in their
communities those would be the stages of
getting into YouTube I think and then
from there you find out about more
people that they work with and through
collaborations and other stuff like that
and this probably was the best that I've
seen now you could say whatever you want
about the home page suggesting more TV
stuff than actual stuff by creators cuz
perfectly honest that I think is a
problem because let me just go back into
this I closed it I opened it we're going
to YouTube okay yeah this looks like
exactly what it was before because like
the number of like individual creators
that I see on this front page for people
getting suggested content is a little
low a lot of its companies a lot of its
TV shows a lot of its celebrities a lot
of its movie trailers a lot of its that
kind of stuff and I get it that kind of
stuff people do want to see but also
there's some amazing content out there
by creators that I think people would
love to see and I think YouTube could do
their creators a favor by putting more
of that forward by having some kind of
curation to get the people that are
making amazing content every day and not
companies and again this is just a
personal bias like I think that
individual creators are what made
YouTube YouTube and I feel like they
should be the ones that are put forward
as the best example of what individual
creators can do and it can really get
new viewers into the heart of what makes
YouTube special but again I know the
algorithm seeks views above all else if
I had to make a tweak
that's the only thing I'd say but
overall this is much better than it was
last year maybe next year I'll be
surprised and when I look at it again
it'll be creators that make amazing
things and it'll be less of the TV shows
and recycled content from companies that
make content like this which is fine I
guess
but the more they do that the more
YouTube will feel like YouTube but kudos
to YouTube for what they've done so far
because frankly this is a step in the
right direction so yeah I guess I'll
make this an annual thing I'm next year
I'll do it again and see where we go
from there or if some big change happens
on YouTube that I need to know about I
will check it out so thank you everybody
so much for watching if you want to see
more of my videos or maybe the last
video I did on this to see it a year ago
it's in the description below subscribe
for more amazing content for me an
individual creator ring the bell to be
notified whenever I an individual
creator decides to get off my lazy ass
and make a video and check out my other
videos that I made I got a bunch like
4,000 it's on my channel click my name
click my face down there so thank you
for watching if you're new to youtube
and you're watching this for the first
time I don't know how you got to my
video but let me know in the comments
below if you enjoyed the video hit the
like button because I'm assuming that's
what it's for and not a thing to be
chased after for the sake of ego I think
we as youtubers don't actually know what
the like button does if it does anything
YouTube would never tell us that's a
fact
subscribe for more content if you want
to see it if you don't know how the sub
box works you subscribe and then you
check your subscriptions on your account
and every time I upload a video it'll be
there maybe but if you definitely want
to be notified when I get a new video
because you love me so much and you love
this face click the bell and that means
you'll get a notification whenever I
release a video which might be at 2 a.m.
I don't I I don't really have a set
schedule at the moment I'm trying to get
back into it but you know things are
busy thanks again and as always I will
see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]